when counting by hundreds from 43 to
1043 which numbers will we say select
all that apply so let's do that
let's start with 43 let's start with 43
and then let's just keep adding a
hundred to 43 so if we had a hundred 243
we're going to get 143 143 now let's
keep adding 100 to it if we add another
hundred we're now going to have to
hundreds 243 or 243 now let's keep
adding a hundred to it so if we add
another hundred we're going to have 343
343 I think you see what's going on here
you add 100 again you're going to have
443 I'm coloring in the hundredths place
so that we can keep track of that you
add another hundred
you're going to have 543 543 then at
another hundred you're going to have 643
add another hundred you're going to have
743 743 let's keep adding 100 and keep
adding 100 add another hundred you're
going to have 843 843 add another
hundred
you're going to have 943 or you could do
that as 900 and 443 or 904 tens and
three ones and let's add another hundred
so if you add another hundred you could
view this as ten hundreds and 43 10
hundreds and 43 but 10 hundreds is the
same thing as 1,000 so we would read
this as one thousand forty three and
that's what they wanted us to count up
to one thousand 43 is the same thing as
ten hundreds and forty three so which of
these numbers did we see when we counted
from 43 to 1,000 43
well we didn't see 44 we didn't see 123
but we did see 143 so we did see 143 we
saw 543 we saw 500
forty-three and we saw 843 so we saw
these numbers now you might have been
able to do this in your hand you might
said okay 43 then 143 then 243 343 434
43 543 643 743 843 and then 943 and then
10 43 or 1040 3 either way these are the
numbers that we found that we that we
said when we counted from 43 to 1,000 43
or these are three of the numbers that
we said